welcome to the heavy spoiler show I'm
your host Paul AKA Deadpool and this
video we're breaking down Deadpool
3E got a quick question for you mate
yeah what is your most anticipated comic
book movie of 2024 is it Madame Webb is
a Deadpool 3 Craven or are you more of a
a more of a Venom 3 man let me know
below and if you say anything other than
Deadpool 3 then you're a complete
scumbag absolute scumbag now that's cuz
it's bringing back Hugh Jackman as
Wolverine and we also know from the
footage on set that we're going to be
getting lots of other X-Men characters
showing up throughout in this video I'm
going to be going through what I've
heard on the film what the Gen leaks are
and also the new Marvel news that we've
had through the week if you enjoy it
please hit the thumbs up button and make
sure you subscribe because it's a it's a
nice thing to do isn't it I don't know
anyway without the wa huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get into
Deadpool 3 hey Hugh you want to play
Wolverine one more
time yeah sure right
okay so last year we had lots of leaks
from the set that showed Deadpool and
Wolverine moving through the void there
they F A Tyler M saber to Toad and each
other and also ran into lots of
artifacts from across the timeline the
footage from that requires a license and
with this just being a small video I
didn't want to Splash out to get
something that's just a very small
talking point you've seen it though mate
you've seen the videos I know what you
get up to on the internet and it's
watching Deadpool tree videos and and
doing something else and it teases where
things are going to go now the build
after this has been discussed in a lot
of leaks and have been cooperating stuff
with sources to find out what elements
are true huge shout out to Daniel rpk
who went through everything with me and
this was so we could nail this stuff
down now he said that Deadpool 3 is
going to center around the TVA who've
now come to realized they can't keep
things in check last time we saw them
they were watching over K and had pretty
much become a law enforcement agency
slowly guarding over him all of the
timelines were allowed to be free and
their mission was to stop him from ever
starting up now from here they
apparently get word that the kangs are
gathering which we of course saw during
Quantum Mania as we know the majority of
that movie took place after most of ly
season 2 with it getting referenced in
the ending time Jump this means that the
council are off doing their own thing
just as the season starts to close out
now Daniel said that he had heard there
had been some changes and that Kang in
himself wasn't specifically referenced
he said that the general leaks are a bit
off and that they just say they need an
army for the incoming War he said that
Kang isn't mentioned specifically but
obviously it it kind of has to be him
doesn't it now that takes us into what's
going on with K who as we know is now
getting recasted Jonathan Mages has been
fired from the role and this comes in
the wake of his recent trial I'm not
going to be getting into the weeds of
that but apparently Marvel have
anticipated this happening for a while
now those press releases mate they went
out faster than Quicksilver and within
an hour of the verdict he was gone in a
Flash faster then he The Flash was gone
you could say
hey now but he's out and we've been
wondering how that's going to affect
things Marvel have stated that they're
going full steam ahead with Kang though
and that he will still be a major focus
of the phase Michael Waldron's now
riding Secret Wars and th it very much
seems like we're still building up to
that earlier in the week it was teased
by Daniel that Coleman Domingo is
currently in the running he said that
nothing had been locked down but Coleman
was currently one of the character Front
Runners have to say I think he'd be
absolutely brilliant and the guys got
the ability to easily do can if you want
to know his work then check out Euphoria
and also Fear The Walking Dead cuz it's
a bit underrated and he's very good in
that now back to Deadpool and what I've
heard is that the TVA is creating a
multiversal group of Heroes that are
from dying worlds that will help to
fight the incoming threat Mr Paradox is
apparently replacing Mobius and there
are rumors he's going to be played by
Matthew mcfaden Mobius will apparently
be back for an Avengers film down the
line but they're pretty much just
leaving them out of this this is
something that was reported by my time
to shine who said that initially they
were thinking of a cameo in the end
though they just cut him out completely
and plan to bring him back in a future
film now I wonder if that's going to
include ly as we've already had teasers
that he's coming back soon what if
season 2 ended with Peggy going to the
world tree and as we know that's what he
created it's where he is and Tom Heston
also voiced him during the series so the
guy's not exactly giving up on him yet
either way it sounds like it's all
connected and if you want to support the
channel we're actually selling it's all
connected shirt right below the video
help support videos like this get made
so huge thank you to everyone that's
picked up on the both of you anyway
we'll apparently learn that Deadpool is
from a dying timeline and that he's not
actually part of the main Fox Universe
he'll have been off in his own while the
main timeline was a Thrust of where the
X-Men films happened now due to his
messing with time in the second film we
learn this put him in the sights of the
TVA he'll be arrested and then locked up
which is when he hears about the
incoming War now from what I've heard
about the film The TVA will be trying to
recruit Wolverine and Deadpool basically
wants to team up with him instead this
will lead to lots of multiversal
shenanigans which will then set up some
of the upcoming films now one of these
could potentially be World War Hulk
which we're now starting to get lots of
info on it's been teased for a while
that something is in the works and Alex
from my Cosmic circus has said it could
potentially release before the next
Avengers film he said it will be a civil
war level Avengers 4.5 I don't know what
the guy sounds like but he said it would
be a civil war level Avengers 4.5 film
uniting all Avengers against the Savage
Hulk and other hulks now just a
disclaimer Hulk's actually one of my
favorite Marvel characters and World War
Hulk is one of his best books I was a
bit of an idiot right and I read that
before reading Planet Hulk the first
time round but it completely works as
its own Standalone thing it's basically
just Hulk coming back to Earth bill with
Rage of being betrayed as in the comics
Hulk was shut off to sakar by the
Illuminati the Illuminati the the
Illuminati who who thought they'd found
a peaceful planet where he could be
alone instead it was the Gad at a
nightmare that was the car and this is
when he rose up and defeated the emperor
The Crafty was in exploded and killed
his wife and he flew back to Earth
wanting Revenge wrecking up shop it
would make such a cool movie and I'd
love to see what they do with the
character I think this would be a great
way to bring a team together cuz let's
be honest The Avengers films they've
been dragged out way too long at this
point and we definitely need a team up
to help unite this phase The Avengers
movies at the end of every phase just
pulled it all together and I think
stuff's felt directional list recently
because we've not had that now speaking
of team ups we've also recently got the
news that stepen yen is dropped out of
the Thunderbolts originally he was going
to play Sentry but he's came out and
released this statement it took a lot of
drafts on email to make sure that I
conveyed the sincerity of how sorry I
was to have to back out he said he wants
to still star in a Marvel movie but
unfortunately due to the strikes in
scheduling conflicts he had to skip this
one Marvel movies at the moment are
getting they're getting constantly
delayed and if you want to stay working
I can imagine that it's frustrating
people are having to clear out their
calendars for years and yeah I can
totally see why people are having to
drop out and personally I'd love seeing
someone like Alan richon in the role as
I think the guy not only looks the PO
but his stars on the rise and he's also
brick house could easily be in
training shape pretty quickly and I
think if you've seen richer then you'll
know he can pull off a Superman type
role which is what the Sentry is other
than that I'd love to see Marvel do do a
little 40 chess move and get someone
like Henry cavalin not sure if he'd do
it because he'd obviously get typ cast
but still I think getting him in the MCU
now he's a free agent would be a very
inspired choice either way that's some
of my ideas and I'd love to hear
thoughts and all the updates and stories
below also if you missed our podcast
happy New Year guys I did say it at the
start of that but I I realized making
this I haven't said it yet to you so if
you if you're watching this without
watching that happy New Year and you
know what even if you've seen it have
another happy New Year as well all the
best for 2024 and huge thank you again
for supporting us through 2023 please
drop a like on the video and if you want
to support the channel as a member of
the spoiler Society then please click
the join button you get early access to
videos every week and it goes such a
long way to helping us out now if you
want something else to watch you got a
breakdown of the what if season 2 finale
on screen right now so definitely head
over there right after this lots of
things to talk about lots of comic
callback so yeah go check that out and
huge thank you for sting through the
video by the way I've been Paul you've
been the best I'll see you next time
goodbye Happy New
Year